- If you forgive the
poor attempt at Irish,
(speaks Gaelic) I'm at home.
(audience clapping)
- [Narrator] President
Biden clearly takes pride
in his Irish heritage.
- As long as I can remember it's been,
sort of, part of my soul.
- [Narrator] He enjoys
dropping old Irish sayings
into conversation.
- If you're lucky enough to be Irish,
well you're lucky enough.
- [Narrator] And when presented
with a Mongolian horse,
named the animal Celtic.
Now, Biden has visited his ancestral home
for the first time as president
in what was both an
important personal pilgrimage
and a demonstration of
American soft power abroad.
The second Catholic
president's visit to Ireland
came 60 years after the
first, John F. Kennedy.
- I want to say that I'm
happy to be here tonight.
- [Narrator] And
continued a long tradition
of US leaders gracing the Emerald Isle.
- I want you to know that for
this great grandson of Ireland
this is a moment of joy.
- Many American presidents
have described their days
either visiting Belfast or Dublin
as some of the best days
of their presidency.
Bill Clinton visited three times.
George W. Bush visited twice.
Barack Obama visited once.
And now Biden, who claims
a lot of Irish ancestry.
- [Narrator] During his trip,
Biden visited the place his
mother's family came from,
met the Irish president and
addressed parliament in Dublin.
- The United States was shaped by Ireland
and that's not hyperbole.
- [Narrator] The influence
of Biden's Irish roots
has long been seen in
his political rhetoric.
His speeches, for example,
often make references to Irish poetry.
- You know, as the great Irish poet
Seamus Heaney once wrote,
"History says, Don't hope
On this side of the grave,
But then, once in a lifetime
The longed-for tidal wave
Of justice rises up,
And hope and history rhyme"
It's everything I've been taught.
- I think for President Biden,
the experience of being Irish
and the historical experience of
Irish living under British rule
is a way that he uses to sort of connect
with oppressed minorities
in other parts of the world.
So he's made it a real part
of his political worldview.
- My background and the
background of my family
is Irish American and
we have a long history
of not fundamentally unlike
the Palestinian people
with Great Britain
and their attitude toward
Irish Catholics over the years.
- [Narrator] Biden's Irish connection
has helped strengthen already strong links
between the US and Ireland.
- I think it's fair to say that today
we're celebrating our national day
with a president who is
unmistakably a son of Ireland.
(audience clapping)
- [Narrator] Being a son
of Ireland has also got him
out of one or two verbal gaps in the past.
- He knows lot about it.
His mom lived in Long
Island for 10 years or so.
God rest her soul.
And although she's,
wait, your mom's still,
your mom's still alive, your dad passed.
God bless her soul.
(audience laughing)
There's an old Irish
proverb, as some of you know,
that I heard my grandfather use
but never really applied to me before.
He said, it goes, "A silent
mouth is sweet to hear."
(audience laughing)
Well, I'm gonna yield to that proverb.
- I think the Irish in
general are very pro-American.
I mean, the connections are obviously huge
because so many of its
sons and daughters left
and many of them went to America
and made something of themselves.
So I think it's nice to have
some of these people return,
create new links between
Ireland and America.
- [Narrator] This is
particularly important now,
25 years since the Good
Friday Agreement was signed.
The landmark peace deal between
Republicans and Unionists
in Northern Ireland was
negotiated with US help.
- I think for America,
it sort of brings a reminder
of the times in the world
when American hard power and soft power
can sort of make a difference for good.
- [Narrator] The President
had the opportunity
during his visit to push
for its preservation
amid political instability in the region.
- As a friend,
I hope it's not too
presumptuous of me to say
that I believe democratic institutions
establishing the Good Friday Agreement
remain critical to the
future of Northern Ireland.
- The Good Friday Agreement is
an unquestioned win for peace
and America was a big part of that.
So I think Biden's going to
rightly sort of celebrate that.
- Your history is our history.
But even more important, your
future is America's future.
(bouncy music)